I have an interesting clip to pay play for
you from Eric Weinstein's podcast, the portal
which I actually listened to.
It's quite an interesting podcast where my
name came up in a discussion with Sam Harris.
Now I want to be really clear,
especially because Eric and Sam might see
this YouTube clip.
The YouTube clip title is sort of a joke.
My YouTube titles are often sort of jokes
we play around satirically with the ways that
it's become sort of en Vogue to title YouTube
clips.
This person was destroyed, that person was
attacked, whatever.
It's just a joke.
So please, the, the YouTube titles are meant
to be interesting.
Uh, but the important thing is the discussion.
It was reported to me over the weekend that
Eric Weinstein attacked me and that Sam Harris
defended me on Eric's podcast.
Now this was actually an interesting discussion
about tactics versus substance.
I think I'm being accurate when I say that
Eric Weinstein and Sam Harris agree with much
of the substance of the left's positions,
but seriously questioned many of its tactics.
And I've spoken with Sam Harris about this
when he was on the program.
So a few names came up during this discussion.
Sam Cedar's name came up and others, I don't
remember who else.
And when my name comes up, Sam Harris says,
David Pakman, I have seen act in good faith.
And Eric Weinstein says, well, not always.
Let's take a listen to a couple of minutes
from Eric's show.
Well, that's ridicule, but you're ridiculing
something that you straw man and didn't understand,
right?
Because the person actually was making sense.
And so what I see is that the left and in
particular the Sam Cedar crowd, uh, has a
doing that with abandoned, it's willing to
do two separate things.
Sarah is quite willing, like there's this
whole thing, but we've talked to Sam Cedar,
will you debate Sam Cedar?
And my feeling is I would debate part of Sam
Cedar, the part that just is focused on the
ideas, but the part that is kind of like nasty
and Riddick and ridiculing and doing the Alinsky
thing.
I don't know what to do with it.
I'm not interested.
I've spoken to Sam Cedar on the phone is perfectly
reasonable, made sense to me.
We disagreed on on positions, but the line
that gets crossed for me always with these
guys, and again it's a, it's disproportionately
on the left is the, the line of conscious
dishonesty.
I miss, it's serious.
Your brother's aphorism, bad faith changes
everything.
It changes everything.
And these guys are in bad faith.
They know their line about, in my case, my
views, my actual beliefs and not all of them.
There's just too much information.
David or Pacman?
No, David Pacman's fine.
I just did his podcast.
Yeah, I know.
But David Pakman said some pretty non charitable
things and some parts that seemed kind of
ridiculing thing.
You, me other people, I haven't, whatever.
I haven't, I have never seen him miss.
He's pretty good.
My views and I think, I mean I again, I don't
know him.
I just did this podcast once, but he seems
like he seems like somebody who, if I said,
listen, you've got me wrong here, that would
matter and he would, he would make an effort
to, that's me.
And that's me.
Right.
Which is the problem that we have increasingly
is that the tactics that are being used in
what are called progressive circles have been
confused with the content.
So that is the objection to the vehicle, which
might be solid and skis rules for radicals.
Um, w is conflated with the totally unethical,
uh, program for smearing people.
Dishonesty,
being non charitable, I actually don't think
is objective.
Leigh a problem.
I, I start from a position of charity and
I think we all should, when we analyze or
critique something, if we find a reason why
someone may be doesn't deserve our fullest
charity, we can re retract that charity in
good faith.
That can still be a good faith action.
We don't have to endlessly steel man.
Every false notion that we hear come out of
anybody's mouth once we have a better systemic
or holistic assessment of their character
and whether they act in good faith or bad
faith, but that's not really the issue here.
Now, Sam Harris asks whether I said things
ridiculing him and of course the answer is
no.
What Eric Weinstein is referring to is a clip
where I talked generally about the intellectual
dark web and I said, you know, it is not as
intellectual as they may want you to think.
And I got dozens of emails from people saying,
David, are you saying Sam Harris isn't an
intellectual?
Each time I would answer calmly and clearly.
I'm not saying that Sam Harris isn't an intellectual.
What I am saying is that less there is less
intellectual ism in the intellectual dark
web.
Then they as a loosely organized group might
want you to think, and that doesn't just refer
to the, uh, stars of the IDW, but it also
refers to a lot of the followers as well.
Now, here's an example just to be thorough
of when someone would ask me very concerned.
David were, were you talking about Sam Harris
not being an intellectual?
Here's just one example of that coming up
and me responding.
Hey David, I just listened to your, uh, take
on, uh, the pseudo intellectualism.
And I agree with most of those folks that
are named in that article.
But Sam Harris, really, I don't understand
how he's a pseudo intellectual.
Is it because he offends, uh, numerous people
and he claims that the ideas of Christianity
and Islam are completely foolish and stupid.
Uh, that's the only thing I can think of.
Other than that, I'm, I'm honest.
Tell me how David.
So listen, I mentioned Sam Harris once in
yesterday's story merely in that he was mentioned
in a New York times article called the intellectual
dark web web by Barry wise.
I mentioned Sam Harris, his name and a number
of other names only in so far as I was telling
you about the article that sort of got me
thinking about the story I did yesterday.
I never said yesterday that Sam Harris is
not an intellectual.
Uh, I've read a lot of Sam Harris's work.
I have some political disagreements with Sam
Harris.
I think that his book, the moral landscape
is endlessly fascinating.
Uh, I've never really taken a position on
whether Sam Harris is or isn't an intellectual.
I, I think, I believe that he is and that's
okay to say that and still say that.
I disagree with some of the stuff that he
said.
My commentary yesterday was not about saying
Sam Harris is not on an intellectual and if
that's mostly what you focused on, you really
missed the point of my entire, okay.
So no, I never said Sam Harris isn't an intellectual.
I mentioned his name yesterday in passing
as one of many, five, six, seven different
people that were mentioned by Barry wise.
I think Steven Pinker was mentioned, I'm not
saying Steven Pinker is not an intellectual.
The commentary was about the environment in
which pseudo intellectual ism and pho intellectual
ism is sort of welcomed and embraced by people.
Uh, rather than about saying who is or isn't
on the list of intellectuals.
Now it is true that for example, Dave Ruben
is not an intellectual, you can agree or disagree
with the, the, the sort of libertarian small
government talking points that Dave Rubin
has adopted over the last couple of years.
But Dave Rubin is not an intellectual and
I think that that is a perfectly reasonable
thing to say.
It's not an attack on anybody.
It's just, I don't even think Dave Ruben would
say, although I don't know that he is an intellectual.
What Eric is referring to, and I've spoken
to Eric personally about this, is that my
comments at the time were probably general
enough that somebody who doesn't know me and
Eric didn't know me at the time and I didn't
know Eric at the time, someone could interpret
what I was saying to mean that there are no
intellectuals in the intellectual dark web
that is of course now very clearly not what
I meant.
But much of the story was actually about the
pseudo intellectual ism in the audiences,
uh, of the IDW movement.
Um, uh, to the extent that those, uh, exists
not about the members themselves.
This is a totally different conversation.
Now at the same time, uh, this is a critique
I've made about people who read, you know,
bill O'Reilly's pop history books and read
nothing else and think they are now informed
historians because they read bill O'Reilly's
take on Abraham Lincoln or whatever.
It is a different story.
And it is a story about the ways in which
the messages from doesn't matter who it is.
And I'm not equating Sam Harris to bill O'Reilly.
Believe me.
It is a story about the followers, which is
a very interesting one actually that I think
deserves a lot of examinations.
So the fair critique of me, based on what
Eric is saying is David Pakman wasn't clear
or precise enough when I made my initial commentary
about the intellectual dark web.
These commentaries, by the way at this point
are roughly two years old.
I looked for my, uh, IDW critiques that Eric
was referring to and I found a clip from may
of 2018 which may be, is the one, maybe they're
even older.
I don't know.
So I know what Eric is referring to.
Eric and I have had nice conversations.
We've been talking about maybe getting him
on the David Pakman show, me being on his
show.
If I'm in LA at some point.
I have proposed some dates to Eric for being
on with me.
I have not heard back, but it's still something
I'm interested in.
I think most of my audience knows that even
if you disagree with me on my conclusions,
I am a good faith actor who simply calls things
like I see them and I am not deliberately
dishonest.
So I, I, I'm fine with this discussion that
took place and I think everybody was reasonably
respectful, although I, I simply disagree
with the characterization of, uh, of, of what
Eric said about my previous comments